[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je dis très juin
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal de tv 78
tout de suite les titres de ce journal
le top départ a été donné à 17h30 depuis
le vélodrome nationale le 17e trophée
des entreprises de saint quentin en
yvelines se tient ce soir plus de 600
participants se sont lancés dans ce raid
multisports nous serons à différents
endroits du parcours dans ce journal
l'échéance approche le baccalauréat
débutent lundi pour les séries générales
technologiques et professionnelles les
élèves de terminale et aussi de première
qui passent les épreuves anticipées se
prépare actuellement et nous avons suivi
l'un d'entre eux enfin il souffle ses 50
bougies le plaisir rugby club fête cette
année ses 50 ans une histoire débute en
1969 et pour célébrer cet anniversaire
une grande journée est organisée samedi
au stade robert barran on en parle en
plateau avec thierry d'amendé président
du prc et nous présenterons également
tout à l'heure l'opéra des enfants de
retour ce samedi au théâtre national de
saint quentin en yvelines avant de
développer ces titres le déplacement ce
soir de christophe castaner haut
commissariat des mureaux est le ministre
de l'intérieur assistera à la cérémonie
d'hommage au couple de policiers tués à
magnanville et jessica schnyder qui
officie au commissariat de mantes la
jolie et son compagnon jean baptiste
salvin major de police aux mureaux ont
été assassinés il ya tout juste trois
ans c'était le 13 juin 2016 attentat
perpétré par un homme se réclamant de
l'état islamique
notre premier point en direct depuis le
trophée des entreprises qui se tient sur
le vélodrome nationale mais également à
lille de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines on retrouve sur place nicolas
d'andry aux moyens techniques mélanie
poké et nicolas le départ a été donné il
ya tout juste trente minutes
effectivement de gori le départ a été
donné à 17h45 les quelques 600
participants sont partis ils
représentent 70 entreprises du
territoire
ils forment des équipes de trois et vous
le voyez derrière moi là je me trouve
actuellement dans la zone de la course
d'orientation
donc il ya cette épreuve au total sur un
parcours qui fait un peu plus de 9 km
épreuve il ya la course à pied il ya la
course d'orientation il ya la relève et
était le golf le bike and run et pour
terminer avant le sprint final jusqu'au
vélodrome national il ya une course de
radeaux et puis on se retrouve tout au
long de cette émission sur le parcours
on découvrira les épreuves que doivent
accomplir les 600 participants
oui vous allez sûrement voulait s'est
prêté au jeu nicolas on vous retrouve
tout à l'heure pour un autre point sur
ce trophée des entreprises elles les
yvelinois en insertion récompensé hier
le département des yvelines et son
agence activity ont remis les
attestations de fin de parcours de
formation
une cérémonie se tenait au siège de la
collectivité à versailles lagence
d'insertion activité a accompagné cette
année 471 yvelinois bénéficiaires du rsa
une remise en activité pour ces
personnes en parcours d'insertion
professionnelle ils ont suivi une
formation dans des filières en tension
qui rencontrent des difficultés de
recrutement dans le département
explications au micro de marylène
iapichino la sécurité classiquement mais
aussi beaucoup de parts trouve insertion
dans l'hôtellerie restauration des
parcours d'insertion dans le bâtiment et
travaux publics mais aussi dans le
numérique dans l'archivage dans les
espaces verts et au delà des parcours
d'insertion qui sont faits pour pour
l'industrie marchande
nous remettons des attestations tous
ceux à tous ceux qui ont accompagné dans
les collèges avec l'entreprise c'est
midi tous les collégiens dans la
restauration et nettoyage des collèges
j'ai opté pour
ressources humaines qui était un peu en
adéquation avec la formation initiale
que la communication est donc moi
c'était un réel plaisir
une vraie chance que
le département a participé au
financement de cette formation
plus que quatre jours avant les tant
redoutée épreuve du baccalauréat en
france plus de sept cent quarante mille
candidats vont se présenter à l'examen
cette année
un moment forcément de stress et pour
préparer au mieux cette échéance la
médiathèque du canal à montigny le
bretonneux propose des séances de
coaching actuellement audrey chaillou cm
bazire et mélanie poker des fiches pour
chaque période historique l1 dit assez
digne passera son épreuve d'histoire
le baccalauréat un examen qui stresse le
jeune homme de 20 ans c'est
un diplôme qui va me permettre d ouvrir
des portes pour mon futur j'aimerais
jusqu'à bac + 5 en gestion de
concessions automobiles comme tu as aidé
mais sont une trentaine de candidats à
être venu chercher un soutien dans leurs
révisions à la médiathèque du canal ils
reçoivent un coaching personnalisé dans
ses derniers instants et sont beaucoup
demandeur de la méthodologie et de la
gestion du temps en fait comment gérer
leur temps sur les quatre heures
d'épreuve et aussi quel choix
stratégiques mettre en place quand on
est bloqué leur donner des outils pour
arriver à mémoriser toutes les
connaissances qu'on leur demande
d'acquérir sur la période du bac tout ce
qui est gestion éventuelle des émotions
du stress de l'anxiété de la surprise
face à un sujet qui nous déstabilise
savoir apprendre de savoir travailler en
fait y'a pas que les connaissances et le
coaching scolaire permet entre autres
permet les permis sa 17 juin top départ
de six jours d'épreuves les résultats
sont attendus le 5 juillet prochain
en 2010 8 86% des candidats de
l'académie de versailles ont obtenu le
précieux sésame
un demi siècle pour cette association le
prc fête cette année ses 50 ans plaisir
rugby club et une grande journée
sportive une grande journée festive
également été organisée samedi 7 au
stade robert barran l2 plaisir et pour
en parler thiery l'amendé bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le président du brc 50
ans pour pour ce club de plaisir qu'est
ce que ça signifie beaucoup trop
monstrueux on est parti quand même
humains les personnes qui ont monté le
club des enseignants des gens de
l'hôpital charcot à la base il ya 50 ans
même un peu plus parce que c'est dans
cinquante ans qu'on a pris le sigle le
plaisir aux beats l'homme en 60
rien donc on a débuté le rugby sur
plaisir au sein de l'asm omnisports de
la ville quoi et donc ils ont tué le
haut débit dans l' essai mais il ya eu
une prise d'indépendance en 1969 la
section rugby de l'asm de cette
association sportive municipale a fondé
son club le plus spécifique au club donc
on le rappelle né en 1969 alors vous
êtes arrivé au club à l'âge de 13 ans et
au début vous l'avez dit alors sinon
anecdote assez amusante vous avez dit à
nos confrères des nouvelles de
versailles au début le sport se
pratiquait sur des champs il n'y avait
pas vraiment de terrain de rugby
les actes les plus tôt un prêt de
terrain par un paysan d'agriculteur de
entre plaisir et les clés d'ailleurs
vous aviez un petit moulin ce qu'on a
représenté son autre affiche des 50 ans
ou c'est là que il s'entraînait qui
jouait le dimanche ils se changer dans
des wagons pour venir il fallait avoir
la foi on dit mme diana à l'oreillette
que l'on n'a pas bien vu à l'affiché
dont vous parliez de ce moulin raconter
nos histoires de ce moulin mais entre
plaisir et les plaines avec eux des
chants et donc je vais à se situer à
moulins et 7 au pied de ce moulin que
l'agriculteur prêté son terrain donc
voilà il ya un lien historique en tout
cas pour ce moulin donc je le rappelle
une grande journée festive qui se
déroule ce samedi
rassurez-nous les installations bien
évoluer un pur plaisir maintenant vous
pratiquer le rugby sur les terrains tout
à fait approprié ben oui c'est sûr que
là au niveau de la municipalité eu un
gros effort de fait et aussi avec tous
les services des sports et autres donc
on a quand même un bel outil est vrai
qu'au niveau de la même en fédérale une
où il ya des clubs sont passées ces
moyens de travaux l'histoire du plaisir
rugby club a été notamment recensé 1
dans ce livre qui est paru l'année
dernière je crois et que vous pouvez
vous pouvez toujours vous procurer sur
le site du plaisir rugby club
quand on évoque cette histoire du
plaisir rugby club qu'elle quels
souvenirs vous vient en tête s'il ya des
noms peut-être des grands noms de
l'histoire du club qui ont marqué cette
histoire du club
oui on a toujours rarement perrier qui
sera présent aussi qui est donc un des
fondateurs avec lucien pêche estrade qui
sera là aussi je dirais que c'était ces
gens là qui ont démarré avec des bd end
et d'un tas de personnes dont des gens
qui sont plus là c'est pour ça qu'on a
voulu faire ce livre est un peu
ne pas oublier les gens ce que firent du
relais ou d'oubli c est malheureux et
donc on est assez sûr c'est cette
histoire pas du club
aujourd'hui le père c'est l'un des clubs
phares de rugby dans les yvelines une
équipe minimes qui a été sacrée
championne d'île de france cette année
les seniors qui évoluent depuis deux
saisons en fédérale 2 qui est le
quatrième niveau national c'est dire que
les résultats sont au rendez vous c'est
un club qui a bien évolué depuis sa
création
oui bon sachant qu'on était déjà allé en
fédérale 2 il ya une quinzaine vingtaine
d'années après j'irai que la
actuellement la fédérale 2 c'est bien
resserré ça équivaut presque à l
fédérale 1 de l'époque groupe a été à 80
club a donc maintenant on est oui
effectivement quatrième niveau et nous
le fait avec nos moyens que je dirais
que c'est surtout la formation des
jeunes du club qui un est un angle fort
sur la formation au club de plaisir oui
puis bon on est obligé quelque part les
avis du budget passe et puis bon quelque
part non plus c'est pas gérer les
feuilles de paie moi ça m'intéresse pas
du tout nous on a créé après 60 % des
jeunes qui sont issus d'écoles de rugby
cadets juniors brest sont des joueurs
les alentours qui viennent nous aider
qui veulent jouer à ce niveau là quoi et
ça représente combien de licenciés
aujourd'hui quelque 190 ans dont 150
avec l'école de rugby jusqu'aux minimes
c'est un canton donc samedi d'organiser
cette grande journée festive de pouvoir
célébrer cet événement avec tous les
adhérents les plaisirs roi peut être
aussi les yvelinois oui bah sachant
qu'on a beaucoup aussi deux provinciaux
ce qu'on s'aperçoit que plaisir war
partout même en province dans même s'ils
sont pas natifs donc on a beaucoup de
personnes qui montent du sud l'on n'a
pas prêt à la soirée de m'asseoir 300
aux adultes et centaines de jeunes sur
400 personnes et quel est le programme
de la journée ça débutera aux alentours
de 10h30 au stade robert barran donc le
matin s'est consacré à l'école de rugby
avec une opposition entre le club de
montfort l'amaury et puis après à partir
de 13h30 on a les minimes cadets 14h30
chez les cadets juniors et après on
allait le match de gala 16h30
sans oublier de 15h30 à 16h30 les filles
qui reçoivent des écossaises et ça se
terminera par une soirée alors qui est
malheureusement déjà complètes
une soirée cocktail + repas devant la
finale du top 14 toulouse clermont un
petit pronostic pour cette finale match
nul pour l'occasion d'acheter une
prolongation
on verra ça donc ça sera au programme
samedi si on doit terminer cet entretien
qu'à l'actualité quel projet actuel mène
mais le club de plaisir donc on a
surtout le bon on va changer un peu
notre salle de réception au niveau de la
du club dans la mairie nous aide bien ce
qu'on arrive perrache allait donc donc
un nouveau club un club house qu'est ce
qu'on peut souhaiter pour les cinq ans
puisqu'elle jour être en fédérale 2 puis
que tous les toutes les équipes se
qualifient pour les championnats de
france c'est le but donc souhaité bon
anniversaire en tout cas attiré l'amendé
à votre club
le plaisir rugby club venez fêter ses 50
ans du prc c'est toute la journée de
samedi à partir de 10 heures 30 au stade
robert barran de plaisir et c'est un
grand fan de rugby justement que l'on
retrouve à nouveau nicolas landry depuis
le douzième trophée des entreprises de
saint quentin en yvelines où est ce que
l'on vous retrouve nicolas maintenant
[Applaudissements]
en nicolas landry qui peut-être du mal à
montendre
oui effectivement vous êtes toujours sur
le parcours nicolas dupouy si
[Musique]
effectivement réglés
et qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que serait le
trophée des entreprises sans ses
supporters
donc voilà qui vaut beaucoup beaucoup de
bruit et je suis avec un sahara bank
sahara qui vient supporter sa tata alors
tata à l'effort dans quelle épreuve mais
je pense les canaris le canoë elle va
gagner sur la course de radeaux et du
coup tu as tu as dit pourquoi voulez
participer tata donc sara quin qu'en
corse à tata qui travaillent à
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et je suis avec lui parce que
parce que l'uso parce que la sodexo
participe au trophée des entreprises
comme chaque année tout à fait comme
chaque année depuis quatre ans
depuis quatre ans donc qu'est-ce que
c'est ce qui motive bravo à la sodexo
qu'est ce qui motive les la sodexo a
participé à cette épreuve sportive mais
je pense que c'est bien être et bonheur
des collaborateurs dont que c'est
important pour justement ça renforce les
collaborateurs l'esprit d' équipe de
collaborateurs
je veux dire partager une passion et sur
tous les supporter supporter les
passions donc on est là on est présent
donc voilà la sodexo elancourt aussi
avec nous
et je pense et je pense que ce soir
elles n'auront plus de voix grégory
merci nicolas on vous retrouve une
dernière fois d'ici la fin de ce journal
ça sera d'ailleurs à la fin de ce
journal et je rappelle que mélanie
poquet vous accompagne derrière la
caméra pour les moyens techniques
culture à présent avec le retour de
l'opéra des enfants la 17e édition de
cet événement se tient ce samedi à 20h30
c'est au théâtre national de saint
quentin en yvelines et c'est le grand
choeur des enfants des écoles de 50 en
une accompagner l notamment de la
maîtrise de trappes et de ces jeunes
solistes qui interpréteront pinocchio un
opéra d'étienne perruchon pour en parler
deux invités autour de sept thèmes marie
astier bonsoir ans a lui signé la mise
en scène de cet opéra et hervé farges
bonsoir bonsoir président de la pms cul
qui est l'association de promotion pour
la musique classique à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 358 enfance
cette année qui font partie du coeur on
peut rappeler quel est l'objectif déjà
de cet opéra des enfants alors
l'objectif d'opéra des enfants c'est
vraiment un projet est un projet qui est
essentiellement sociales et culturelles
le but est en fait de mettre les enfants
sur scène plutôt que les mettre dans une
salle pour qu'ils découvrent la culture
en la jouant plutôt qu'en la regardant
en passant huit mois à apprendre des
partitions parker et ensuite se
retrouver tous ensemble sur le plateau
de la scène nationale où ils vont jouer
devant un public on va attendre mille
personnes à peu près dans ce public il y
a les familles il y a le public un
public de saint quentin et ça permet
aussi donc de aux familles de venir voir
leurs enfants sur scène mais dans un
spectacle d'immenses exigences ces
derniers dont semblent ça revient ce que
vous disiez il ya un côté social dans ce
projet de vivre ensemble voilà c'est
vraiment le vivre ensemble puisque là
par exemple cette année on va avoir des
écoles du des clayes-sous-bois donc d'un
quartier plutôt privilégié on va avoir
des écoles du vally boua plaisir qu'ils
y sont des quartiers prioritaires et ça
je crois que c'est une première avec ses
collègues qui ont intégré saint quentin
en yvelines en 2016 tout à fait c'est là
une première donc on est très content
parce que
l'association promotion musique à 50
euros des mines ça veut bien dire saint
quentin en yvelines et nous sommes une
association culturelle qui travaillant
sur l'ensemble de saint quentin en
yvelines
on a donc en fait travailler avec toutes
les villes de saint quentin jusqu'à 2016
et puis deux piles 2016
il va nous manquer plus que coignières
maurepas et et la ville peut il vivre
voilà la dernière ville alors l'opéra
l'opéra proposé cette année c'est
pinocchio inspiré bien sûr de l'oeuvre
de carlo collodi en 2007 c'est le
compositeur etienne perruchon qui a créé
cet opéra sur un livret de sa femme
jeanne perruchon etienne perruchon qui
est décédé en mai des suites d'une
longue maladie c'est un hommage que vous
avez voulu lui rendre
en fait c'est un tout petit peu un
hasard qui est devenu en fait un hommage
c'est à dire que ça fait huit mois que
le travail est ce que ça fait de leur
travail sur ce sujet on avait énormément
apprécié travailler avec etienne
perruchon puisque après on a joué deux
autres spectacles le premier stade de
gora en 2010 où il avait joué à vélizy
et puis en 2000 duce qui donne et c'est
quelqu'un d'assez extraordinaire cet
opéra 2000
en 2007 il avait créé pour nous et en
plus il nous en a fait cadeau ce qui est
quand même assez sympa pour un
compositeur parce qu'il nous a pas fait
payer la halle avec la création et on
avait envie de le redonner donc je les
contacte et en juin l'an dernier je les
ai eus on a longuement discuté ils
étaient très contents de leurs données
et d'ailleurs je lui avais fait signe en
demandant si viendrait avec son épouse
pour les 12 ans de sa création
et puis ça a été le drame c'est ce qu'on
a appris le 16 mai qui était décédé donc
ça sera l'occasion de lui rendre hommage
sur cette somme très fort marié dont
vous signé la mise en scène pour cet
opéra pinocchio
déjà sur le côté hommage imagine ya ça
aussi quelque chose de particulier pour
vous de présenter cette oeuvre
ben oui c'est quelque chose de
particulier pour moi moi c'est ma
première mise en scène d'opéra et je
trouve effectivement que c'est un bel
opéra pour saint quentin en yvelines
parce que 350 enfants sur scène qui sont
là c'est vraiment intéressant
est ce que je trouve beau c'est que les
individualités ne s'efface pas dans le
groupe
et ça je trouve ça vraiment intéressant
dans le dans le coeur et l'âme à mon
idée c'était de faire en sorte que les
choristes chantent mais aussi fasse un
peu entre deux mers partie du décor donc
je vous dise tandis pas trop pour que
vous puissiez venir moment ils font les
vagues qui sont vraiment partie
intégrante c'est pas juste je me lève je
chante et ensuite je me rassois j'ai une
responsabilité aussi en tant que
choriste différentes mais toutes aussi
importantes que les solistes c'est
important de le préciser c'est un opéra
écrit pour les enfants vraiment ils y
tiennent les premiers rôles comment on
met en scène un tel opéra justement
alors moi ce que j'ai essayé de faire
c'est est d'adapter en quelque sorte au
public c'est à dire que pour donner un
petit exemple le chat et le renard qui
sont un petit peu des loubards j'ai
vraiment fait dans les costumes des
souhaite à capuche avec un c dans le dos
et un air et je leur dis bah voilà en
fait ils sont en train de donner et
pinocchio il a de l'argent et on va
aller lui piquer son argent et du coup
tout de suite j'ai essayé de faire en
sorte que les enfants s'approprient
vraiment cette histoire d'un petit
garçon enfin d'un petit bout de bois qui
devient un pantin qui devient un petit
garçon mais qui traversent des épreuves
que eux aussi peuvent traverser tous les
jours et comment on s'en sort qu'est ce
qu'on en pense
pour essayer de les impliquer vraiment
dans l'opéra et dans l'histoire que
sarah cook et le tout avec un mélange
des genres ce que ça s'appelle pinocchio
en tout cas cet opéra créé par étienne
perruchon le l'opéra classique
finalement et aussi la comédie musicale
il est quand même relativement classique
dire que autant tchikidan et dogora
était plutôt effectivement des comédies
musicales
autant là c'est quand même un opéra est
un opéra fait pour des enfants et donc
les airs c'est vraiment de la musique
très travaillé c'est en fait c'est un
très grand compositeur etienne perruchon
c'est très très travaillée c'est très
très difficile très difficile à chanter
autant pour les choeurs nos intervenante
musicale
nous disait vous êtes fous on va jamais
y arriver mais là les voir ça va être
extraordinaire reste des places il reste
des places mais il faut réserver très
très vite
1 et voilà est alors l'intérêt aussi
s'il voulait c'est que en 2007 pour les
airs très difficile on avait fait appel
à la maîtrise de paris
c'est donc la maîtrise qui chante avec
eux leurs caisses de paris à la
philharmonie donc voyez le niveau et
maintenant ça c'est la maîtrise de
trappes en yvelines qu'on a créé en 2011
qui va chanter et donc les rôles
d'enfants elle sert des rôles de soliste
très très très difficiles et vont être
chantées par des enfants de cette
maîtrise ce sont des enfants qu'on a
repéré au moment du spectacle les
enfants de bernis en 2011 et qui depuis
sont à la maîtrise et vont chanter les
rôles de pinocchio et je précise parce
qu'on arrive à la fin de cet entretien
que la billetterie est ouverte sur votre
site le site qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran merci à hervé favre merci à
marie astier donc que vous signez la
mise en scène de cet opéra pinocchio
desforges président de la paix m excuse
depuis presque trente ans ils subliment
les plats de l'abbaye des vaux de cernay
alain pontoise au et le sommelier de la
table du prieur il a récemment été
attitré du titre donc de maître
sommelier par ses pairs une distinction
qui récompense sa passion marylène
iapichino signé son portrait donc la
présenta son sein sera bas je pense moi
ce sera comme ça après je pense qu'on pu
le faire comme ça
cet après-midi-là au restaurant le
prieur de l'abbaye des vaux de cernay
chef cuisinier et chef sommelier travail
sur les accords mets et vins de la
nouvelle carte vous arriver un moment
oui ça fait 14 ans qu'on se connaît on
s'entend très bien
14 ans d'une collaboration quotidienne
pour des repas haut de gamme constamment
en évolution
tous les plats sont dégustés avec toute
l'équipe de salle et la cuisine et je
dirais même au cours du premier service
ont refait encore or on apporte quelques
ajustements alain pontoise au s'occupe
des caves du prieur depuis 29 ans les
600 références ils sont classés de
manière bien précise
c'est un plaisir c'est que quand on sait
que les bouteilles sont bien rangés et
touche obtient d'abord roncal dans une
maison parisienne il y rencontre un
membre de l'association des sommeliers
de la capitale ici dès son amour pour
l'art des cépages
une passion qui ne le quitte plus et
dont il fait son métier c'est pas mieux
que paisible et de temps en temps je me
dis bien même dépasser 15 minutes avec
en tout en regardant les étiquettes se
lavent notre havre de paix à la table du
prieur il développe sa carte la
sommellerie est un savoir ancien mais
alain pontoise hausse et prendre en
compte ces évolutions le vin etc tous
deux vivants on ne peut pas dire je fais
une carte je garde les vignerons pendant
30 ans je vais garder les mêmes millions
vignerons je gage de changer le
millésime je pense que là
je pense que je fais pas mon métier le
sommelier géré sa cave
mais il travaille également en salle 18
tables a conseillé à chaque service
vous me direz tout les verts avant de
partir cet après midi s'il vous plaît
faut aimer les gens parce que c'est vrai
que le sommelier dans une maison les
personnes me pose beaucoup de questions
on rentre on a la chance d'avoir des
contacts avec des clients
et puis et puis avec le migneron qu'on
va dans le vignoble c'est vrai qu'on a
des moments des changes quand même
qu'ils sont qui sont importants voilà
donc jeu intéressant régulièrement alain
pontoise or en visite à son ancien
apprenti enzo oc a commencé en salle
avant d'embrasser la même passion que
son tuteur
aujourd'hui il est assistant sommelier à
la table du 11 à versailles c'est plus
mon c'est plus mon apprenti maintenant
c'est celle d'un homme qui puisse et
dégustation il fait ses voyages il est
avec un nouveau chef sommelier donc il
découvre d'autres choses que moi j'ai
pas pensé ou j'ai pas découvert où j'ai
pas déguster un mentorat qui prend
aujourd'hui une forme d'amitié
l'ancien apprenti est fier de montrer
son nouveau terrain du on peut rentrer
donc les promoteurs peuvent vous pouvez
donc sur le monde la vallée je me dis ok
ça c'est vraiment sympa donc c'est un
vigneron qu'un hectare de vignes et les
personnes qui nous ont transmis
certaines choses qui nous ont
qu'ils nous ont éduqués qui nous ont
appris je pense que dans dix ans car bon
c'est pas impossible que j'appelle un si
j'ai un souci sur un accord une
transmission au coeur du métier du
sommelier alain pontoise au a fait de
l'univers du vin sa deuxième famille
avec laquelle il entend bien continuer
de nombreuses années prochain challenge
potentiel le concours de meilleur
ouvrier de france avant de refermer ce
journal on retrouve une dernière fois
nicolas landry depuis le trophée des
entreprises je le rappelle c'est eu un
raid multisports nicolas qui regroupe
les sociétés 1 du territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines et ça va se
poursuivre ce raid pendant toute la
soirée
effectivement magori ça va se poursuivre
et là je suis actuellement sur la
dernière
l'avant dernière épreuve de ce trophée
des entreprises c'est la course de
radeaux et je suis avec or
habituellement il est directeur du
service logement de 50 ans divine mais
aujourd'hui il s'occupe de cette épreuve
antoine beau bonjour bonjour bonjour
arriver les radeaux l'épreuve mythique
qui tue trophée les entreprises
auparavant c'était des canaux et c'était
trop facile on est passés avec des
radios ou d'un pâté rit pas très stable
c'est beaucoup plus drôle
on est là pour les accueillir il va
avoir deux cent vingt équipes qui vont
passer sur ce sur ce circuit de radeaux
savate assez bouyer arrosé stratégie
pour réussir cette partie et bah il faut
être coordonnée quand même parce qu'on a
deux pas guère un devant et derrière
issus du milieu et regarde le paysage
qui profitent de l'île de loisirs et de
voir les la nature voilà grégory et on
connaît la stratégie pour les radios
alors aucun participant pour le moment
aucune équipe n'est arrivé mais ça va
pas tarder donc ce sera l'avant dernière
épreuve et ils finiront avec un sprint
jusqu'à l'intérieur du vélodrome
nationale et peut-être quelques instants
nicolas pour vous entraîner au radon
vous remercier et on remercie également
mélanie poké au moyen des techniques
nous reviendrons d'ailleurs sur cette
12e édition du trophée des entreprises
ce sera demain dans l'émission 7 8
l'hebdo présenté par aurélie ronze dans
un instant c'est marylène iapichino vous
retrouver aux commandes de son 7,8
loisirs elle vous donnera toutes ces
idées de sorties pour le week end à
saint quentin en yvelines et dans ses
environs voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal est belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]